opération faucardage pendant trois jours
l'ennemi a éradiqué la jussie une plante
d'origine brésilienne qui prolifèrent
dans les marais au fond des feuilles
longues feuilles langues
alors avec des racines traçantes et tout
le monde et tout le long de ses racines
vous avez vous avez des autres racines
si bien qu'elle s'ancre au fond de la
rivière et elle va elle va traverser la
rivière et après vous aurez vous pouvez
plus passer en barque d'abord vous
pourrez et en plus ça tu voulais tout ce
qui est tout biodiversité
cette année la jussie s'est installé
durablement dans les marais et pour
cause c'est au printemps qu'elle doit
être arrachée sauf que cette année
confinement oblige impossible d'en venir
à bout
aujourd'hui elle prolifère jusqu'à
obstruer certains coulent ans alors vous
voyez l'autre derrière ils étaient
nettoyés donc en pratique derrière mais
celui ci il est impossible vous pouvez
pas pratiquer le nom or c'est un passage
obligé à la barque pour certains
propriétaires qui veulent rejoindre
leurs parcelles et pour les autres une
pollution visuelle
c'est un triste spectacle quand même je
sais pas dans quinze jours il va y avoir
une fête démarre à 1 bat quand vous avez
les gens quand ils sont unis à venir de
la pique est ce que voulaient au bout
d'un moment c'est qu'on me l'arraché
bien sûr je proclame sa monture le
marais faut pas déconner non c'est non
faut pas que ça ça vaut rien sans ses
machines dans les travaux de faucardage
ne permettront pas d'éliminer tous les
plans de jussie le seul moyen efficace
d'atténuer sa prolifération
c'est de l'arracher au printemps